welcome you all have a detailed printed
program and I bet that you can all read
and I won't drone at length repeating
information about the history of this
annual event or the illustrious
achievements of this year's anointed
lecturer but I will drone for a minute
we instituted the Kenneth n waltz
lecture in international relations for a
lot of reasons having to do not only
with that respect for Ken but also out
of gratitude for his contributions to
Columbia both early and late in his
career the fact that man the state and
war was written here now a half-century
ago is one of the great credits to the
Institute of War and Peace Studies
now the Saltzman Institute and the fact
that Columbia students edged out
Berkeley's for the benefit of Ken's
classes in recent years or just a couple
of things for which we're grateful and
we're fortunate to have James furanose
the fourth lecture in the series for all
the reasons you can see in his bio in
the program the subject of anarchy in
international politics is one dear to
Ken's heart to some who don't pay close
attention to its definition by the
theorists who apply it the term anarchy
carries normative baggage that makes
them wring their hands or makes its
application to international life
uncomfortable to others it's no more
than a or less than a bland empirical
description it looks like our speaker is
going to complicate to clarify and
challenge some thinking about this
simple but often emotionally charged
term then we'll hear from Ken about
whether he's got it right
take it away professor if you're on well
thanks thanks very much for that nice
introduction thank you all for coming
and thanks to the committee or a group
or whatever who who invited me to give
this lecture I'm I feel you know greatly
honored also a little bit surprised in a
good way
I hope in the email I got from from dick
it came with her said you can talk about
any topic you want as long as it
involves in quoting significant
commentary on IR theory I definitely
have commentary on our theory whether
it's significant
I think that's toe you know for you to
judge what I'm going to be presenting is
very much the sum I was unclear about
what to do I was going to present
something in the manner of a paper
that's already written it could be a
journal article someday hopefully but I
decided to kind of throw that out and
try something a lot more novel really
some some possibly still rather
half-baked ideas but maybe better suited
to the vivir agenda here but if you find
it hard to follow and confusing
especially as I get towards the end it's
not entirely your fault ok so I also
want to end very happy to be given this
kind of opportunity to thank Ken
I'd like to thank him not only for his
guidance and support as my dissertation
adviser way back when at Berkeley but
for something else as well which is
really for providing kind of inspiration
for my career when I started grad school
I'd never taken an IR course I had only
a very vague notion of what the field of
IR was what it was about in fact I had
really not much of a concept of what
political science was about having never
major or having not majored in that in
college when I got to Berkeley
can I think was on leave I was in fall
of 86 and I think he might have been on
leave the next year as well or he was
there wasn't teaching the ayah and a
graduate I our course and in any event
as a result I never actually took a
graduate course from can I did end up TN
for him a couple times but I never
actually took a course so in my first
year while he was away I was Mike Mike I
did take some semi our courses this is
my introduction to this field I knew
nothing about and it was that year I
read man state and war and theory of
international politics and and these two
books were just absolutely decisive
influence on you know people are
sometimes asked what are the most
important books you've ever read in your
life in my case is probably these two
books in terms of certainly in terms of
influencing shaping determining my
career path and work life those two
books really they lay out a set of
arguments ideas questions and also a
style of thinking that I basically been
working on ever since and probably and
will continue to work on as long as I'm
probably researching and writing okay so
so moving on to the lecture so as I said
this is this is new stuff it's it's a
little bit probably gets progressively
incoherent as we go along Bell be
interested in kanzen and your reaction a
central claim of realism as probably
everyone here knows is that anarchy
absence of supranational government
makes for all kinds of bad things often
refer to as tragedy war in particular
what I take to be a central idea in
Ken's 1958 book was that a lot of
interactions in international politics
have a structure like prisoner's dilemma
and because of the situation the kind of
structure of the situation where they
can't write contracts with each other
and then have them enforced by a third
party you get bad outcomes this is a you
know the you know a dominant theme in
u.s. ir scholarship the last 50 years
recently say John Mearsheimer book
2001 titled the tragedy of their great
power politics the tragedy he argues
coming from the fact of anarchy and
implications of anarchy on the other
hand you've got critics of realism who
think the consequences of Anarchy don't
have to be so horrible and that you can
get at least partial fixes to the
problems posed by Anarchy by essentially
tit for tat like deals helped along by
international institutions for helping
with monitoring and facilitating
sanctioning and so on so if you think
about it there's a real puzzle here so
realists who think that anarchy is
tragic and very bad are the people
generally most opposed to world
government strongly opposed whereas the
critics of realism who think that
Anarchy need not be such a terrible
thing are more likely to think world
government is like okay and maybe a good
thing and a direction to head in so
something is kind of confused here or at
least as confusing there's another
example I want to give that that heresy
that comes from Harrison Wagner it's not
exactly the same but it actually is
I think embedded in the same confusion
or puzzle Harrison noted in his book war
in the state that Mearsheimer in his
tragedy of international well he says
anarchy is the cause of this tragedy of
great power politics a few years earlier
John and other self-described relaxed
realists are forcefully arguing that
only partition can resolve the violent
conflicts in the former Yugoslavia in
Bosnia and Kosovo particularly so there
he and and others are arguing that only
an turkeys making making a bunch of
separate states is this you know is the
way to solve a problem of war which is
kind of you know very much at odds with
what one would take to be the central
argument of his 2001 book so what's
going on here there's a kind of
incoherence or conceptual issue it's
worth worth trying to deal with so why
do realists dislike the idea world
government if they believe that anarchy
is the source of tragedy and great costs
a first answer that might come to mind
is that this is the long shadow of a
famous argument by eh Carr it said more
or less don't put your trust in the
tap for quarter steps away from anarchy
like the League of Nations or the United
Nations you know they'll it'll it'll it
was a mistake because you're not really
gonna get there well that that doesn't
really answer the question that I'm
interested in since it doesn't explain
why a realist wouldn't support going the
full monty like going all the way to
real world government with supranational
control of force military force so what
I'm gonna argue today is that the answer
to this question is pretty obvious and
it's probably occurred to all of you
already but that it's almost completely
unstated and certainly undeveloped in IR
theory and developing it leads us to a
quite different theoretical take on well
a different theoretical take on
international politics than we get from
the current way we teach and conceive of
the field of IR and this is true for
both whether you're a realist a liberal
institutional type or a constructivist
the correct answer I think to the
question why oppose world government or
the most defensible argument for
opposing it despite seeing cost Anarchy
is this a global monopoly or a near
monopoly on military force would be very
risky relative to the status quo of
Anarchy for strong States since
institutional and constitutional
constraints at a world government level
could fail putting control of force in
the hands of a group or a coalition with
very different preferences from your own
so for example if if poor regions gained
or grabbed enough control of the world
government forces they might try to
attacks rich regions to redistribute
global wealth or perhaps some region
with different ideas about religion or
proper cultural practices might try to
impose these on your region know that
this could happen even without any
failure of the institutions if somehow
you had an agreement on a world
government that was actually democratic
so what's important to see here is that
the problem of world government is
exactly the same problem is that of
constructing political order within a
state the parallel is particularly clear
if you think about founding
it's like the US and 1787 or civil wars
where the combatants are fighting to
control a central government the problem
for of world government in the u.s. case
or federation there was how to reassure
small states that they would not be at
the mercy of more populous ones which
led us as everyone knows to the creation
of the Senate Rep which represented by
state which in turn enabled agreement on
Federation in that case in a largely
peaceful way in civil wars or a lot of
them the problem is that while fighting
is very costly the captains fear that
power sharing would not be stable and
that one side might be able to grab
control of the army or larger put the
large part of it and use it then to
crush their former enemies so that's my
first main claim that the problem of
world government is the same as the
problem of how to establish political
water at the lower level of the state
and that's not just to say that both are
problems of how to create order out of
Anarchy but giving a specific structure
to that problem namely given
organizations or groups with conflicting
preferences over something like tax
rates or cultural religious policies how
to design political institutions so as
to credibly commit everybody not to grab
the means of coercion and then try to
impose their preferences over an
institutional compromise but that claim
if it's right immediately raises another
question a second question which is if
it's possible to solve this commitment
problem with institutional design at the
level it'll call the domestic or country
level then why not at the global or
let's say you know regional level it
could be a regional level as well but
why not the global level or to put a
little differently why does the problem
get solved at the country level but not
at the world level so that we have
hierarchy within countries and anarchy
between them and here's my second main
claim or set of claims are a kind of
rough answer to this question I'll argue
that the problem gets solved at lower
levels rather than higher levels and
especially at the global level for two
main reasons
first the efficiency gains from solving
the problems associated with Anarchy are
much greater at more local levels in
smaller Geographic spaces for smaller
political organizations and this is
basically an offense defense logic
offensive advantages are much greater
when the competing groups are smaller or
you know in Hobbes's limit at the level
of the individual as you get larger
scale of political organizations over
larger geographic spaces this is by
itself significant defensive advantage
lowers the costs associated with anarchy
makes forming higher-level government to
get rid of these costs less urgent
second the greater the conflicting
preferences among groups or factions the
harder it will be to construct political
institutions that reliably solve the
commitment problem and what I'll argue
here is that conflicting preferences
among states and countries have been and
continue to be quite large greater than
as often or usually the case within them
and for two major at least in
present-day
I think it's varied over time but in
present-day for two main reasons income
inequalities as I kind of briefly
mentioned which raises this kind of
redistributive the issue that would
would block any kind of democratic world
government and second the doctrine of
nationalism which associates political
legitimacy with distinct cultural groups
and the enactment of policy said to be
consistent with the values of these
groups now this argument about the
effect of conflicting preferences across
units or groups on attractiveness and
prospects rural government is a little
tricky the more conflicted the greater
the conflict of preferences the harder
it is to construct institutions that
would credibly commit parties not to try
to grab power overturn a particular
distributive bargain but at the same
time the grave the conflicting
preference is that also increases the
cost of anarchy it makes Anarchy less
less pleasant by increasing military
efforts to a deter or prevent attack and
you know what I'll argue here is this
going to depend in some ways on the
nature or the roots of these conflicting
preferences I'll argue that the spread
of democracy tends to reduce conflicting
preferences across states arising from
material advantage or economic
motivations for conflict although the
spread of democracy has at the same time
aggravated or kind of gone along with
conflicting preferences due to Nash
motivations of nationalist conflicts
the net effect or you know I have to
kind of at the end of the day in terms
of contemporary world what I'll say is
that in a world with nuclear weapons
which creates in you know tremendous
defense dominance and spreading
democracy among the the stronger states
but huge income inequality the cost of
Anarchy are not very large and there's
little motivation or reason to choose
world government or International
Federation the point in this case is
that Anarchy is not particularly a bad
thing in real issues you know view it as
basically a good thing not a tragedy and
so on but a second best policy that's
probably pretty you know a pretty good
one in terms of overall efficiency now
justice and fairness is a wholly
different matter and one could you know
well argue that you know massive income
redistribution at the global scale was
the just thing to do I won't be
addressing that I'll be talking more in
kind of a tradition of IR theory about
efficiency now note how this argument
and framing is different from the
standard approach we tend to take
whether you're a realist or or other
varieties of thinking about
international relations in the standard
story anarchy is just an inescapable
fact a natural what called a structural
condition of international politics and
the argument is over what the
implications of that fact are so in the
standard story the structural condition
of Anarchy is enough to cause big
problems and major inefficiencies
between states even if they don't
actually have much or any significant
conflicting preferences this is said to
be the result of this thing called the
security dilemma in the account I'm
suggesting international anarchy is not
a structural condition but rather a
choice that the strong states make
because given the fact of their
conflicting preferences they fear that
they would not be able to construct
super national institutions to guarantee
them outcomes at least as good as what
they get under anarchy so in this
approach we're putting conflicting
preferences and their routes
in you know the nature of the units you
know democracy autocracy nationalist
anarchical at the heart of the analysis
for example you know I'm suggesting that
nationalism is a central part of the
explanation for why the present-day
international system is structured as it
is and also as you know you know kind of
clearly a source of conflict note that
nationalism plays essentially zero role
in our current kind of IR theory
discussions alright so that was the
introduction that's done I'm gonna I'm
going to talk hopefully some of quickly
about explanations for Anarchy that
might come out of current I don't know
there are various explanations you might
pose for why the international system is
an article that I think are either not
properly developed or or just not right
I'll talk then a little more about this
problem of world government and the
analogy between it or the connection
between it and the problem of
constructing political order at lower
levels factors that bear on the choice
between anarchy and hierarchy and then
and then some implications at the end
can you give me a like a time I should
try to end by and I'll try to shoot for
that okay thanks okay all right so first
explanation for Anarchy now you know
before starting here note that if I
asked an audience of IRS scholars to say
what explains why international politics
is considered you know it takes place in
an anarchy it's not like there'd be a
set of well-developed
arguments here it's not just not a
question that we asked it's just that's
just that's just a fact it's taken as a
natural kind of given so these are
attempts to kind of extract out of
existing theory what what one might say
if you were trying to develop the
argument there so very very influential
argument from from from Ken's theory of
international politics he said
or one could one could make the argument
that he is saying anarchy follows from
state's desire to survive and this is a
natural place to start an ir theory he
says kind of bedrock assumptions state
seek to ensure their survival I quote on
the slide a couple codes that have been
repeated many many times by other
theorists you know Charles Glaser
recently John Mearsheimer and so on and
these provide a justification for this
spout you know this basic assumption one
of them worth reading survival is a
prerequisite to achieving any other
goals that a state might have other than
the goal of promoting their own
distributed disappearance and then
another much quoted line only if
survivals assured can save States safely
seek such other goals as tranquility
profit and power so as I said a very
influential line of argument and
justification for kind of making this
making the assumption of States seeking
survival like the analogy analogy to the
assumption that firms try to maximize
profit in economic theory I think that
this argument actually doesn't work or
doesn't doesn't really go through it's
not the case that survival is a
precondition or the justification for
the assumption I have doubts about
whether is survival really a
precondition for other ends a state
might plausibly have such as say
economic well-being or you know profit
of the leaders let's imagine two states
whose leadership SAR both interested and
say say they're democracies and they're
well they're good democracies and their
leaders are interested in maximizing the
per capita income of their countries or
let's say they're autocrats who are
interested in Max and maximizing their
you know their net tax revenues well it
could in both cases it could well be
that in principle the best way for them
to maximize income or their their rents
would be to federate or unify to take
advantage of free or trade the unified
legal system and most of all a lower
defense burden you don't have to spend
defending against other if you could
manage to unify or federate that is
surviving as an independent state could
well actually be an obstacle
not a precondition to maximizing the
income of the inhabitants of the
territory in other words it's not a
precondition to the goal of maximizing
income of the inhabitants or your income
as a leader but actually an obstacle now
I don't wanna belabor this point too
much but let's consider the analogy to
micro economic theory a little bit more
note that economists do not assume that
firms in an oligopolistic market have
some primitive preference for survival
as a firm what they're interested in
doing is maximizing profits okay and in
fact the best way for them to maximize
profits in an oligopolistic market would
be if they could to merge into a single
firm that was a monopoly okay why
doesn't that happen in basic models of
oligopoly like Fortran under cournot
models it's just ruled out by Fiat and
the justification the implicit
justification is that they're operating
in a situation where there are antitrust
laws where which just prevent them from
having the option of forming a cartel or
merging into a single firm so they're
just not allowed to do that in
international politics however there's
no antitrust law and there's no enforcer
for antitrust law so merger or
Federation is certainly an option States
could take if they wanted to and we need
an answer for why they don't want to and
the answer it can't be I think that they
just you know because they survival is a
precondition for other ends they might
plausibly have because it just isn't I
mean if you were trying to maximize
income it seems more like an obstacle
all right okay second argument for
anarchy very interesting work by Alberto
Alsina and Enrico scolari summarized in
his book they published some years ago
size of Nations I think there's a very
original interesting approach to kind of
some fundamental issues and I are pretty
much missed by by our field over in
political science and what I
particularly like about it is that they
take a normative perspective here so in
our approach we just kind of accept that
anarchy as this fact state boundaries
are service you know kind of a given
these guys ask well if we could do is
design an international system what
would be the optimal number of nations
and where
you draw the borders and this is you
know it's very abstract and high-level
but it leads you to to ask the kind of
this normative question like well what
is good or bad about our current setup
and the way they you know what their
argument is is that there's a core
trade-off between economies of scale and
government on the one hand and something
they call heterogeneity costs you know
economies of scale in government if you
have fixed cost or providing some
service like defense and you know it's
cheaper spread over a larger number of
people as with a number of other
government or public goods but on the
other hand they say well the more
diverse a group you have in your country
the harder it is to satisfy people with
a given public policy because there's
more people who are whose preference for
you know their preference is farther
away from what you know say they are you
know a median type policy would be so so
there's kind of a you know in terms of
trying to satisfy people's preferences
you've got this trade-off where you know
they have to pay lower taxes to you know
provide the public goods the bigger your
country but that's lowering their you
know their average person's satisfaction
because they're getting farther away on
average from you know any given policy
or a median policy that's chosen okay
and then they argue that things that
effect the importance of economies of
scale like free trade regimes or benign
military relations among major powers
will then reduce the optimal size of
nation so you know you you you can have
you know you you need defense less and
you can satisfy these heterogeneity
preferences more about having smaller
states that are you know closer to the
median person in a smaller zone in terms
of their preferences all right so I
think this is a very you know as I say I
like the approach but I think that
there's a problem with the way they do
it or that they're there's you know I
don't think this okay well what what is
the argument here for Anarchy it's
basically saying it's an efficient it's
it's efficient to organize the world in
two different states because that way
you're satisfying people's different
cultural preferences say by you know
allow them to have governments that
serve them with policies that are closer
to what they like and if you had a world
government had to oppose you know one
kind of uniform policy over everybody
problem here is that they don't really
provide a developed argument
why not for a more complicated
arrangement which would be to have
multiple jurisdictions why not have you
know you know one giant federal this
jurisdiction for a use-of-force say and
then you know a federation of countries
that can implement whatever cultural
policies they want say at a lower level
you know we see this kind of approach of
multiple jurisdictions within many
countries currently you know there's
local control over school districts and
so on arguably in the medieval period
you had a very elaborate system that
we're overlapping jurisdictions
religious and princely and economic and
so on that did not involve territory
Leda limited sovereignty in a manner of
the modern state you can think about the
European Union has a kind of an attempt
to get a more efficient kind of multiple
jurisdictions with some overlapping and
some not now Alice eNOS Villar I kind of
realized that this is a possibility but
they sort of push it to the side by
introducing a concept called economies
of scope see but yeah they kind of rule
it out by saying like well what if there
are costs you know that it can be more
efficient to bundle provision of
services with one organization and they
kind of force getting territorial
sovereignty that way but if we think
about the specific structure of the
public good of defense economies of
scope and heterogeneity costs aren't
going to explain why it wouldn't always
be best to have a world government kind
of at the highest level of jurisdiction
to minimize you know defense cost
spending on arms and let lower-level
jurisdictions deal with issues where
there are significant heterogeneity and
preferences I think the real problem
with that kind of solution is how to
guarantee the control of the defense or
military power at the highest level
wouldn't be hijacked by a minority that
would try to impose its particular
cultural preferences for example on
everybody else
so okay last argument for why we have
anarchy this one from Hobbes so
basically a one sentence remark in
Hobbes which is a very interesting
suggestion why didn't Hobbes argue for
world government if he thought that
anarchy was such a terrible thing and he
certainly did think that and
was a really terrible thing and you know
one of the things he did with he
famously gives international politics as
an example you say look you can see what
happens between states this is the bad
stuff that happens with anarchy
why didn't he then follow that on and
say well why did he offer argue for
monarchy but not for a universal
monarchy he says essentially nothing
about this except for one line at the
end of the famous chapter 13 which is
which is up here and he gives you this
example of the anarchy of IR and then he
says but because the princes there you
know uphold their by the industry of
their subjects there does not follow
from it that misery which accompanies
the liberty of particular men so this
appears to be an argument that
international anarchy is not such a bad
thing as domestic anarchy let's call it
because the competition among Kings
causes them to want their countries to
be economically prosperous so they can
defend their Thrones so the idea being
that this international competition
limits monarchs abuses of their own
citizens and further there is even a
suggestion here it might be an engine
for economic progress which is a you
know becomes a key theme of much later
people like hints and Tilly talking
about the rise of the West so there's a
deep point a very interesting
observation here but if you think about
it's not really an answer the question
of why anarchy
since it would still be in the
sovereigns interest the Kings interest
to avoid the costs of international
anarchy by setting up some kind of
universal government just as Hobbes
argues that at the level at the lower
level it's in in people's interest to
set up a government to get them out of
the state of nature that is by this
argument anarchy might be OK for the
citizens but we what we need to explain
is the decision of the sovereigns you
know why don't they want to escape the
anarchy that they're in with respect to
each other
ok so ok so so yeah I've kind of done
that all right so so why international
anarchy so as I noted at the start I
think the right answer is pretty obvious
but that it's not been fleshed out
because the question we just don't ask
the question and that you know fleshing
out is is an interesting thing to do the
problem
as I've said a couple times now escaping
anarchy would require setting up an
institution with the global monopoly or
some kind of control over military force
accompanied by or implanted by disarmed
and meant or at least kind of control of
national armies the problem for leaders
of states party to you know a conference
to consider building such an institution
as happened in more or less in Paris in
1919 and in San Francisco in 1945 would
be how to devise political institutions
that would guarantee control of this
force in such a way that it would not be
used or threatened to be used to back
policies that you don't like or it would
make you worse off than you were under
anarchy let me use a diagram to
illustrate this and we're gonna think
about a very simple world which is two
states one it's pretty rich the other
that's relatively poor the poor state
has a larger population than the
relatively rich state so on the
horizontal axis here we've got the rich
countries per capita income let's say on
the y axis the the vertical axis to the
larger poor countries per capita income
represents like a status quo and anarchy
the dark line does the curve would be
like that kind of the the maximum
possibly efficient resolutions where
kind of the countries are producing as
much as they could and those are the you
know the feasible distributions of kind
of maximum output let's say it's curved
outward because of gains from trade or
tax costs of implementing redistribution
Anarchy keeps you away from that the
green arrows indicate costs of Anarchy
that might arise say because in Anarchy
they need to arm against each other so
they need to spend some of their money
you know kind of uselessly on weapons
and paying for soldiers who aren't
otherwise employed and working so
there's representing the cost of Anarchy
now well so why not get yourself out of
Anarchy agree on some on a world
government between the two states to get
yourself out to a mutually better
outcome well if say you try to implement
a democratic world government and the
there are more poor people than rich
rich people the rich the rich guys would
worry that in the in
the new government they get voted higher
tax rates that would redistribute
perhaps to the red point in which case
no we don't want to go in on we don't
want to leave anarchy at all but we're
better off in Anarchy even if it is
inefficient so the problem here you know
for the is a commitment problem how
could the poor state credibly commit by
some kind of institutional design not to
redistribute or not to use there there
are larger numbers to affect some kind
of transfer scheme like that and that
that would be you know that's the core
of the problem now note that this
example it doesn't have to be in terms
of a tax rate we could equally well make
the argument terms of cultural or
religious policies or regulatory
policies or whatever okay second note
this is exactly the same problem faced
by political units contemplating
Federation or by parties embroiled in a
civil war so I'll quickly you know just
show the maps exactly on to say the
problem faced in South Africa in the
early 90s how could the ANC commit to
not redistribute
heavily after going to you know
something like an actual democracy you
know it's just just relabeling what are
the costs of anarchy you know anarchy in
quotes here well it's you know the
violence of the of the 80s and the the
conflict with the ANC and second you
know cost of sanctions are keeping you
away from the you know maximizing the
pie that could be divided the problem
for whites with higher income and
privileges how is that going to be
protected enough that they prefer taking
a risk on the you know a democratic
government and you know I it's not a
case I know as well as I'd like to but
various people argue there's a you know
a federal solution with with federal
units that constant you know with the
whites relatively concentrated into two
provinces which had you know kind of
extra control over distribution of
pblicas in and transfers within those
Provinces that did the trick also the
ANC you know abandoned in 91 or 92 the
demand for you know a kind of strictly
majoritarian democracy and we're willing
to compromise on that but you know to go
quickly same kind of problem in should
be 1787 America with the Constitutional
Convention how to guarantee the small
states preferences the the large states
you know what are the costs of anarchy
here well if you read the Federalist
Papers this isn't focused on a whole lot
but the first like eight or nine of them
the the core argument for why we should
have a federal government is a concern
about costs of anarchy and that if we
don't do this we're going to be arming
against each other foreign powers will
form alliances with our separate states
and this will create you know costly
military competition on our side of the
ocean so it's very much anticipating a
kind of a costly piece costly and risky
piece that is making them argue for
let's escape this you know prospectively
costly anarchy by forming a world
government essentially over here and
they do this with this institutional
trick of the Senate
you know famously turns out the kind of
large state small state conflict isn't
really realize or maybe you know maybe
because of good institutional design but
then it does become absolutely critical
with the you know southern states veto
in the Senate on slavery you know at
keeping the Union together at least for
60 years or so okay here okay so note
that in oh yeah and last example you
know this is just a current or but it
could be could be multiple cases a civil
war case think of 1990s Afghanistan the
black point is is the status quo
fighting for control of the state the
cost of Anarchy in that case are quite
obvious why can't they get to the
frontier by forming a stable power
sharing government well because of
concerns that you can write it down on
paper about someone may you know grab
control of the larger part of force
you've disarmed or or you know to
escaping the cost of anarchy there's
some disarmament is going on you're more
vulnerable and what if you end up on the
losing side of it which ends you up at
you know a red point or a blue point
which would be even worse than the
status quo of continuing to fight for
you know military victory on your own
okay so something to note here is that
in two of these two of the three
examples I've given the problem of
institutional design was actually solved
and a domestic anarchy let's call it
that was replaced by a higher argument
if the institutional design problem can
be solved overcome within States why not
at higher levels including the global
level well and here I don't know I don't
have a full answer the question about
and particularly the question of you
know when under what conditions is going
to be possible to construct binding
institutions that you know adequately
resolve this these reassure the parties
and make them think it's safe enough to
go in out of anarchy I think it's a you
know it's a big question and it's an
important question to work on but you
know what what can I do I think I can
say something about two variables that
in in a fuller explanation would would
almost surely figure and these are
offense defense balance and the extent
and the nature of the conflicting
preferences between the the political
groups or States okay alright so I'm
going to use a model to try to be
specific or clear about this I'm not
obviously going to get are not going to
get into too technical details at all
and I'm gonna try to go quickly but I
think this is useful for just kind of
illustrating the the different choices
and trade-offs and this is based on you
know great paper by Bob Powell another
Ken Wald student from nineteen
ninety-three papers called guns butter
and anarchy so let's think again about a
two-state world and they're gonna have
budgets government budgets g1 and g2 and
they're gonna choose and successively
how much to spend of their budget on
arms there each of them will have when
they make a choice like they decide how
much to spend on arms and then whether
to use that to attack the other side and
if you attack the other side there's a
chance of winning which
depends on the arm the balance of arms
and obviously the more arms you have
better your chances of winning more arms
the other guy has the lower your chances
of winning going to war it's gonna be
decisive one state wins the other loses
but their costs which it's going to
reduce the flow of revenues for the
foreseeable future in two different ways
you can handle that that's that's a
simple way to do it and then finally big
big thing I'm going to talk about two
types of states democracies and
autocracies so in an autocracy these gee
numbers the government budgets those are
like rents for the autocrat stuff you
can spend on your palace you know having
a garden at Versailles etcetera things
like that
alternatively we can think of
democracies where we think of the
governed by just this is stuff you can
spend on public goods or that's you know
stuff that goes to public goods you know
whatever you don't spend on arms and
stuff that's spent on them for the
benefit of the public
hopefully okay so what happens in that
world well there was basically two
possible outcomes you can either have
you know the the parameters are such
that there will be a stable balance of
power at positive arms levels so I'm
going to talk about autocrats
okay so first let's talk about autocrats
who you know just consume what they
don't spend on arm arms as rent so
that's what they want in the in the
simple game there's two things that
could happen there could be levels of
spending such that each side is happy to
live with that level of spending and
doesn't and is doesn't see an advantage
to ramping up in a period and attacking
the other side and and so you know we
got a stable balance of power each
period and this is an inefficient
outcome they're spending money on arms
they'd rather be able to strike a deal
where they don't spend anything but
that's not stable because you know once
I could cheat on the agreement by
building up the army and then taking
over the other side so that's one
possible outcome but it can also happen
that there is no stable balance of power
and that the amount they because the
amount they would have to spend on arms
to deter the other guy from breaking out
and attacking is so high that it makes
just too unpleasant and you'd rather
it's too expensive you'd rather just
take the chance of fighting a war and
say you know winning even with the
probability of 1/2 after which one side
is eliminated and and this simple
two-state world you don't have to spend
anything more on arms if you're the
winner so you've got kind of get rid of
this efficiency inefficiency produced by
the arms competition or the need to
balance power so in that case and this
is you know this isn't her slifer's
model but he has a nice paper in 1995 GE
where he talks about the breakdown of
anarchy it's natural to think in this
case if that's a case where anarchy
breaks down into hierarchy via conquest
ok so what if what determines whether
you get anarchy or hierarchy well the
more the offense defense balance favors
offense and that here is cashed out or
understood in terms of how sensitive is
your chance of winning two small changes
in your level of arms if that's very
sensitive then then you know small
increases in your armaments giving you
what the other guys spend and give you a
big bump on your probability of winning
that's offensive advantage that's a
situation in which you're likely to get
the war outcome rather than be unable to
support peace with the balance of power
so the basic lesson here is that
offensive advantage makes peace with
deterrence and I'm going to apologize to
Ken for abusing the word deterrence
which we talked about a lot when we were
when we were in Berkeley years ago and I
take your point I think you're right
about that so let's call it peace with a
balance of power rather than deterrence
with offensive advantage enough of it
it's just the piece is too costly and it
breaks down into hierarchy the main
thing here I think is country scale so
Hobbes does have this wonderful line
about or when he's giving his analysis
he says you know why can't it be
sufficient just to have small groups
rather than large countries always says
with small groups the advantage that
accrues to one side of the other from a
small difference in a you know getting a
few more people is to great and that's
basically an argument saying you have to
get up to a sufficiently high scale in
order for a kind of enough defense
dominance to to kick in that anarchy
would be would be stable
I'll skip over for lack of time talking
about railroads and nuclear weapons I'll
say a little bit more later okay so but
this analysis I've neglected a third
possibility which is what hobbes called
sovereignty by institution i've been
talking about sovereignty by aquas it
what do you call sovereignty by
acquisition or conquest you could also
the states could decide the autocrats
could say well why not cut a deal it's
just unified have one state will divide
g1 and g2 between ourselves and not
spend anything on arms or just enough to
keep down revolts from our subjects well
the problem is that they're greedy and
they know that each one would want to
stab the other in the back basically now
that's that's a quick answer and then
here's where I don't have a good
developed answer it's not completely
clear why they can't construct clever
institutions to you know to get to that
outcome all right now let me talk about
democracies so now let's think about
supposed to two states have the same
population so that now we can think of
you know G 1 minus a 1 and G 2 minus a 2
as the per capita spending on public
goods after you've spent on the military
all right now and now I want to make
provision of a provisional assumption
which I'll talk about in a minute but
let's suppose that these are these are
good Enlightenment democracies in the
following sense that if one of these
democracies takes over the other one
they'll extend the same citizens from
citizenship rights to the people in the
territory that they that they conquer or
otherwise get control of alright take
that as a provisional you know let's ask
what would happen in such a world where
you have nice Enlightenment democracies
that really believe in political economy
little equality of persons and so they
they would they wouldn't either for
instrumental or just straight normative
reasons exploit people in concrete and
territory that conquered or at least not
indefinitely well then what do they get
out of winning a war well you just you
you know you've got a bigger population
and you're going to divide the total
public good spending over everybody but
there were cost to the war to get there
you know the expression would be you'd
get the average of the two country's
total public goods Reno
tax revenues but lowered by the costs of
war and you know the but lowered by the
cost war so that if G 1 and G 2 are
closed there's no advantage to going to
war it'd be better just to spend nothing
on arms and get you know G 1 if you're
in the first state or G 2 in the second
state whereas by going to war you could
build some arms and take over the other
side but what do you get out of it
you're you're not going to be
expropriating from if you're not going
to be expropriating from people on the
other state
you've just paid costs of war and you
haven't increased your public goods
spending at all now that would be a
little different if there was a big
material difference between the states
so a poor democracy might have a reason
to take over a rich democracy to in
effect to you know get redistribution
from the richer people but if they're
relatively close in economic size then
no good economic reason for war so think
about the US and Canada what would the
point be of us taking over Canada you
know it would only there would only be
some material point if we were gonna
like make the Canadian slaves and and
you know you know work them to extract
money and ship it down to the US for us
but you know it's hard to see that
happening you know if we just made them
other states and they became States in a
larger Union what do we get you know
it's you know not a whole lot okay so
all this is to say that you know in the
model if you have economically similar
democracies you can have a stable
anarchy with little or no arms costs now
let's ask the question about sovereignty
by institutions would they want to unify
well at least in this model it doesn't
make any difference you know you know
the models simple like if there were
advantages to unification like say you
know freer trade or more secure
cross-border investment or something
like that then you know there could be
advantages to Federation or unification
and it might even be easier to construct
with democracies because democracies
already have a technology for
self-enforcing institutional you know
commitments democracy but we could also
say that the motivation for them
forming world government is lower
because you know compared to to
autocrats they don't have to spend as
much anarchy if you don't have to deter
each other from from conquests
there's a the other side of the ledger
there's less of a reason to escape
anarchy as well okay so I I was going to
talk a little bit about some empirical
support for this I'll just just comment
that in kind of you know a very rough
measure a cost of Anarchy would be
military spending and you know it's
striking that when states transition to
democracy their military spending on
average reduces a lot
there are also some neighborhood effects
so that if other countries in your
region go Democratic then your military
spending tends to decrease some -
although the effects are smaller okay so
a key assumption in that little story I
told was of course that democracies
would extend political you know
citizenship rights to people in
territory that they an extra took over
now and we can think of democracies
where this was just where this wasn't
true the Athenian democracy definitely
democracy when they you know understood
conquest they would enslave kill and
enslave the the men in the place they
took over take a bunch of the land and
redistribute it to their - Athenian
colonists so they were not a nice
democracy in the sense also worth
pointing out that people who studied
this period think that the Democratic
peace does not hold in in in ancient
Greek times so I think is a but I think
Enlightenment democracies the stories
are different and that they've been
there's a political there there's a
commitment to formal equality of people
as citizens if you look at the you know
the first great debate international
relations between imperialists and
anti-imperialists in the late 19th
century about should the u.s. become a
colonial power it's interesting that the
anti-imperialists never argue for they
always argue that eventually the places
that we take over would become States
and would become you know equal parts of
the Union it might take a long time but
the assumption and the whole discussion
is that yes you know it's our core
principle is that all everyone's equal
then and eventually they would get the
same political rights the British and
the French empires are also constantly
making
excuses along lighten Minh grounds for
yes you know eventually we're committed
to political equality now I think you
know there's other well okay so no I'm
sure that a whole bunch you are not
buying that right and are thinking oh
there's all kinds of ways that
democracies figure out extract stuff
from places they takeover or dominate
and I think that you know that's there's
something to that even if that's true
we're still gonna see some difference
between democracies and autocracies in
terms of the benefits of conquest
because if it really is democratic
you've got to spread these ill-gotten
gains or you know these gains gotten by
military force over a larger number of
people whereas in an autocracy it's you
know it's smaller number of people get
these gains and so that's by itself you
know even if you don't want to grant me
this notion that Enlightenment
democracies are going to be reluctant to
conquer without you know and enslave
let's say I think it's another reason to
think that you know the extent of
conflicting preferences between material
preferences coming from democracy is
going to be less between democracies all
right nationalism
so economic interests are not the only
source of conflicting preferences though
across States nationalism I think is
another really really important thing
that we just don't talk about very much
you know you know people in political
science do well but not really in the
context of international relations
theory so what is gone your governor has
got a nice definition and I think it's a
good way to do it he says nationalism is
a this what is in truth a nearly
universally accepted doctrine of
political legitimacy that you know what
is what makes a government have a right
to rule the illegitimate rulers in a
country and the doctrine holds that the
political and the national unit should
be congruent and what Gellner says is
that sent me what does national mean it
essentially means a cultural unit so a
political you know a body of people
understood as you know a cultural group
although you know there are exceptions
and you know we've got the Pacific
versus ethnic nationalism but that's
this is a pretty good start a corollary
to this
gulnur says is that if the rulers of a
country belong to a nation a cultural
group other than that of the majority of
the ruled this for nationalists
constitutes an outstandingly intolerable
breach of political propriety all right
so if you just think of that think about
that I mean that's an immediate that
causes an immediate problem for this
question of like how would you form a
world government to share power and in
fact it's it's just a negative of having
an authority over your over your country
if you think it's you know illegitimate
or like it's just a downside to have
rulers not from your nation but think
about a little more that I think there's
you know there's diverse and nationalism
cuts in in multiple directions and I
list three here so first of all as I was
just saying it provides a really
important I think source for conflicting
preferences between states that's just a
direct obstacle or to constructing
institutions of world government I mean
obstacles maybe not the right word this
is this is kind of along the lines of
Alice Tina and spiel re notion that you
know it would just be you know
inefficient or a bad thing to have
world government or this would be a cost
of world government and that you'd be
making people unhappy nationalists
unhappy as you know in our in our
country people who are really worried
about black helicopters feel that's one
effect of nationalism second effect
though as you know it's not as is the
case for many things I've said here not
an original point nationalism is a huge
source of plausibly a source of defense
dominance so when you have populations
that managed to get ethnically or
nationally sorted with borders it and
who and they're nationalists it becomes
harder to take them over because they
dislike being ruled by some other
cultural group so that that factor would
point in a direction of making Anarchy
less bad by you know for the reasons
described earlier the more you have
defense dominance the lower the cost of
Anarchy the less the less you need to
spend to make yourself to sustain a
balance of power then but finally
there's a kind of a downside here in
terms of or creation nationalism creates
these conflicting preferences along
borders where you don't have sorting as
at least some nationalists envisioned it
ought to be and that of course creates
conflicting preferences that as we think
about cases has made for costs of
anarchy and in many cases Wars I went
through the correlates of war list of
interstate Wars for from 45 to 2001 and
did a really rough and ready coding of
you know how many what which of these
conflicts involve conflict over the
nationalist principle as galaz gulnur
defines it and I tried to be i was
really generous to the you know the the
alternative view so for example coding
the Vietnam War as having you know just
being about ideology and I still got
about two thirds of them being centrally
involving nationalist principle with
some some listed there okay so to sum up
in the standard approach anarchy in NIR
and not just in realism but but but you
know the
the realist set up in this sense
structures the way the critics of
realism think about things as well
anarchy is a given a structural
constraint and you know we start with
the structural fact we add the survival
motive we throw in military capability
we throw in some uncertainty about what
other states might you might do with
their capability and a bunch of
conclusions are said to follow and we
have a lot of argument over just what
those conclusions would be and you know
some you know claim conclusions are you
know it's a self becomes a self help
system we should see balancing there
will be security dilemmas they're going
to be tragedies of international
relations I'm suggesting an alternative
development where we think we're where
we go this way we start what we start
with the primitives are regime features
and doctrines like nationalism and these
give rise to greater or lesser
conflicting preferences across political
communities so we have these conflicting
preferences we add in facts about
offense defense balance technology
military technology Geographic and you
know the offense offense balance here is
going to encompass as well aspects of
the organization's of you know military
organizations and state organization as
well those factors plus this mysterious
problem of institutional construction
you know you know when how can you
figure out how to construct political
institutions like the u.s. founding
fathers did in 1787 this we you know
these things determine whether you get
state construction at one low you know
at one level or at what level states are
constructed whereas and where you get
balancing at a higher level so here
rather than Anarchy being a cause of
balancing balancing as a cause of
Anarchy for one thing so so this gives
so Anarchy in other words derivative
it's kind of endogenous to these these
prior things it is associated with
inefficiencies like armed spending some
wars perhaps maybe and we can think of
economic political economy things as
well concerning trade and Finance but on
balance what I'm saying is that strong
states are
using these and prayin you know in
preference to an attempt to construct
world government because the cost of
Anarchy are really not that bad
relative to the risks of world
government given these underlying
conflicting preferences so the last
slide some implications of this thinking
specifically about contemporary anarchy
we're saying it's not you know you know
that thinking about there being a big
tragedy here is incorrect and I think
here I'm I suspected can will agree with
me that in a world with nuclear weapons
would I'm sure Ken would see is the key
thing and I think I think it is super
important but I'm going to add other
stuff as well nuclear weapons in a world
with Nationals doctrine makes for very
strong defense dominance add to that
democracy among many of the strongest
the most capable states in the world
plus high incomes among them and we've
got little reason for conflict over you
know material conflict between them in
the way that in you know the age of the
old regime with Kings and all they had
you know good reasons to want to take
over the other guys peasants because you
know you could have a bigger and fancier
court and keep your throne better at
home so these all things make for a
world where Anarchy is not very costly
not such a bad thing
add in you know another feature of a
nationalism just mentioning if it's a
because this direct preference for not
having people from other cultural groups
you know above you in terms of rule then
you just have very little incentive or
ability to construct an actual rural
government but at the same time and
again for due to nationalism lots of
border conflicts resentment and cultural
de domination based conflicts connected
with the spread of nationalist doctrine
around the world in days when the cost
of Anarchy were larger you know there
could be tragedy and big Wars but I'd
say think about that as driving from the
failure or inability to construct
political institutions robust against
capture and you know essentially the
same problem is what we've seen say in
Afghanistan for
you know 20-plus years now you know to
come back to you know one of the one of
the puzzles I started with this analysis
makes it very easy to understand why you
can have cases where creating Anarchy by
partitioning States would be actually
welfare improving and this is going to
be in precisely those situations where
conflicting preferences make first best
institutions you know world government
like or higher level institutions
infeasible so so I think that resolves
this puzzle of or you know it you know
this confusion about arguing on the one
hand at Anarchy is a tragedy but are you
doing that well in Yugoslavia you know
we got peace by breaking them up into
central separate states so I'm done
thanks very much
I don't know how much Kent has to say
about this but you'll have a chance to
say it
as foundation I think that if you send
between countries that certainly
something new
among countries that previously appeared
as the major
and I think Jim's presentation goes far
to explaining why that has happened
most other factors remain constant or at
least some economic competition
differences nationalism nuclear weapons
that submerge
how do you do what kind of effects to
ignore the fact so we've never had we've
never had little water and of course and
I believe we never will and the Box in
the example
Bertie nominee of course of Missile
Crisis and afterwards a significant
thing about the Cuban Missile Crisis is
that when the countries involved with
your vendors involved approached the
abyss and looked over the edge what what
happens is despite all of the writings
rages time counter
most of the residents at Brody who saw
the types of danger and that solid media
Missile Crisis doesn't as being the
greatest effect every two more things
are even world existence the weapons
also happen if you approach to you this
what you want to do is that show 32 to
go to the brain as it was I think what
was their background and the persuasive
the arguments for the establishment of
this period I'm president and period of
peace
very much mittens persuasive
presentation
if people have questions please line up
behind the microphone in the middle
you know I could count on yes Mike a
interesting you do genders can work in a
regional context the obviously I think
is Europe today and you can also perhaps
if we take the Vigilant also break it
down the things that are in between like
Federation I didn't in between hierarchy
paradox without warming the form what we
call the security community that is
making war is not impossible there in
very unlikely but if you get to the
point that the Europeans have where war
among them is let's just say simply
impossible then the incentives to go
further become less not zero there are
all sorts of other things you talk about
but do become I would think less so one
question is whether
paradox that sort of when you think of
this dynamic that you have a huge shape
in the sense that if you get in the true
law where war is impossible it's much
harder to know further and I wonder if
you think that might be right in the
second Israel democracy in this movie
were the conflict for the complicated
between democracy and constructing
institutions that provide a unit and the
people in it with the confidence that
their rightful respected and the
American hostage may be the best it was
happened we can talk about I think it is
fair to say the Senate and other aspects
of very undemocratic in the sense of it
and that was the protection if you move
to a system that is highly democratic
meaning
power among people then is not
compatible with warming institutions it
will give people any confidence so
you've talked a lot about how
democracies can encourage this process
but is there a conflict between
democratic institutions and institutions
that can maintain commitments is on
black I mean you know that there and
there's a good arguments on why the only
way to maintain things on the credible
commitments is things that in fact or in
any sense so how do you want to do
things in this way
want to take them one at a time for now
unless you're gets to be a huge line
okay so let me first thank hanford speak
to Ken's comments and thanks very much
and you know I I i very much agree with
you about nuclear weapons i think that
they are the kind of the you know i
don't know the final the final word and
and and i think it's an interesting
question as to how much you know this
think of it as a club behind far behind
the door is affecting you know relations
between power you know so if somehow
they they could they would disappear
would that have kind of escalating
effects and and i think that's a point
that goes to my claims or would be you
know potentially an argument against
some of the things i've said if for
example you get rid imagine getting rid
of nuclear weapons and then despite you
know fairly democratic major powers and
you know nationalism if you know you
then would still see like an escalation
of insecurity and and arming and return
to alliances then then that would would
cut against what i was saying i do wanna
say about about I don't think nuclear
weapons are the only thing that's going
on and
true that we haven't had a major power
war or significant one anyway for a long
time which is which is great but if you
look at the in the longer term
perspective you take a longer-term
perspective the amount of great power
war has been declining for a long time
and there were two you know massive
great power Wars of the scale when they
have occurred you know their intensity
has increased in terms of like number of
people killed per year but the the
frequency with which great powers of
thought has been in decline since you
know the 1500s and and it's actually
haven't seen or read the book yet I
guess this guy Steven Pinker talks about
this or but but you know various
political scientists have seen this in
the data for some time so I think and
and so that decline long predates
nuclear weapons so that so there are
some some some longer-term trends that
are going on and that those are maybe
the things that I would be trying to
speak to with these arguments about
democracy and nationalism
Bob's comments so yeah I I think I agree
with both and this is something I
haven't got really resolved in thinking
about it yes there is this contradiction
or attention between no cos oh I'm
saying that on the one hand conflicting
preferences increased the cost of
anarchy but at the same time they make
it harder to you free for you to
construct a you know a governmental
solution to the problem on the other
hand if you know we get rid of the
conflicting preferences then the chaos
of Anarchy go down the incentive to you
know the cost of Anarchy or lower
there's kind of less lessening and
lessening you to try to fix the problem
by constructing higher level
institutions so so yes and I don't know
about you know curbs going up or down
there I just see it as you know effects
that work in in different directions but
that generally I guess in both case
cases militate against a world
government sort of solution
likewise with democracy yes I think
that's right
that you know if if to the extent that
democracy is going to be have a mature
majoritarian core aspect that you know
certainly at the international level
makes it you know I sent to say
impossible you know there's no way that
the rich countries would go in on any
kind of international scheme in which
poor countries could vote tax transfers
away from them you know significant ones
anyway but I think it's also worth
pointing out that if you look at
actually existing democracies you know
truly majoritarian democracies are like
spotted owls like they're they're really
rare and if you really look at the you
know institutional setups of democracies
they all virtually always have very
significant the anti majoritarian
institutional features and my colleague
Barry wine guys has a paper kind of
pointing this out and talking about the
the genesis of this and the very many
ways that majorities are checked in
actually existing democracies you know
that would certainly be true is
certainly true in the European Union and
and it's would be true in any kind of
world government solution I'm sure it's
true in the United Nations just one
minor qualification that point about
nuclear weapons is true on significant
there's been no major award between
states with nuclear weapons but there
have been too small limited wars between
states with nuclear weapons on the
Ussuri 40 odd years ago and in Kargil a
decade ago on the asuri River and in
Kargil yeah well that's what I said but
qualifications matter next
we lived in a world with totally
completely barriers and meanwhile the
key media to everyone's mind
the energy what did you wish you were to
somehow create a sense of security the
world's assuming you're a leader and
sort of well so the answer is is kind of
along the lines of how I learned to love
nuclear weapons that you know what I was
one of the arguments was that you know
in the current system the cost of an
anarchical world are really it's really
not it's really not so bad and I think
to have a view you have to take a long
view and think about how bad things were
in the first half of the twentieth
century and and at earlier times but I
agree very much with Ken here that's not
to say that you know nuclear weapons
don't create significant insecurities
and you know the Dane you know sooner or
later one's going to explode and it's
you know in a place with a lot of people
and this is going to be absolutely awful
and so I would like to see clever
thinking about you know here I might
differ well I don't know I don't differ
but clever thinking about international
institutions to improve control of
fissile material and possibly moving in
kind of direction of centralization in
that area but you know so I guess I
guess that's that's why I say I want to
thank you so much for validating like
you a nuclear power I've been published
about it and my view is that I want all
the nuclear power I can patent and
including area 51 so my question is with
the idea nuclear power does it make a
lot of sense I would prefer a world very
much in which Iran did not have nuclear
weapons but why can I think I see in the
long run it's it seems to me unlikely
that that's a
that's a well actually I don't know I
mean it is feasible I think that an
attempt to prevent them from acquiring
nuclear weapons by by military means is
you know in the long run unlikely to be
successful and would kind of guarantee
that you'd have you know further
attempts and possibly increases
likelihood of use by Iran in the future
of nuclear weapons so I think it's a
difficult problem like I say I'd like to
see them not acquire nuclear weapons but
I don't see yeah I agree with
observations can and others have made
that you know we've we've been terrified
of each kind of new new almost every new
nuclear power as they've come along and
it's turned out to be less horrific than
than expected and I would actually
expect that to be the case here as well
but I completely understand being
terrified of an Iran with nuclear
weapons
lecture i my question was about I find
your argument or presented this report
even that explanation
weapon democracy and nationally my
question is does it follow from that
that as those things increase we should
see more ampere that is a proliferation
of states or is there something about
reserve cost-cutting
the Bob were discussing that
the numbers except a small city near
Samarra directly but it seems to me that
while we have seen a proliferation of
states if liberation has not happened
among democratic
I'm sorry Sanders has
first time it has happened in a world
where there's a very strong let's say
international regime of border of fixed
borders and and no attacks so it's
relatively safe to come into the world
these days as a tiny little state which
was not really the case you know in in
the first half of the 20th century and
and at the latter half of the 19th
century so you know when you've got the
US and formally the Soviet Union kind of
essentially standing behind and
protecting in an indirect way you know
preventing invasions among smaller
states that becomes more feasible to
have a world with a lot of little States
no I suppose that it would depend like
if there were no the Union did yeah yeah
you know so a democracy where say you
know that's divided by you know where
the people in it are divided into groups
who imagine themselves to be very
distinct nations and you know subscribe
to nationalist doctrine might very well
break up you know Czechoslovakia so so
yes in some cases but you know if
insofar as there are some economic costs
to you know there are economies of scale
like Al CN n Scolari talked about then
why would you break up you know what
would be what would be the point
thank you for your question
you emphasized that contemporary
energies so that may not be so bad the
universe assume that the quality of
energy is different from our different
yes that's a core part of the argument
right that that the quality of Enter key
or how costly anarchy is varies with
things like the extent and nature of the
conflicting preferences across political
units and the offense/defense balance so
in that sense it's similar to things
that where I know there's definitely
connection with Professor Gervais is
famous
culture language person and it said that
I also like that question how can one
describe the last 5060 years history of
humanity period one person and three
piece where one had tens of millions of
people at the victim of war and military
machines that and now have extended
beyond the traditional confines of war
among military who born in society once
had uninterrupted proxy wars in every
single continent in the world
so so the last 50 or 60 years have seen
very little interstate conflict there
has been quite a bit of civil war and
lots of people killed and displaced and
all kinds of bad things in civil
conflict it's really a relative
statement certainly on the interstate
front the first half of the 20th century
was just vastly vastly worse than the
last 50 years and just you know just
look at the just look at the numbers of
people killed in this place and the
lives ruined in in the first two world
wars there's just no comparison to what
you get from interstate conflict after
1945 civil war is another story and
there has been quite a bit of that but
even even you know if we want to kind of
try to get rough measures the scale of
the killing and injury and civil wars
since 1945 is not doesn't doesn't come
close to the
world worse
well these I mean you know so one could
think that this is like one can make a
say ultimate maybe that was really bad
right
I'm not did I say I never said that this
was like a good or I'm not even sure
exactly what you're referring to or you
know I guess with the CIA support for
the Mujahideen but you know that could
one could argue that one way or the
other but but you're not going to get
you know so it could be I'll grant you
it could be a bad thing but if we're
talking if you're saying like how could
you say that we've had a you know a
narrow piece well just I'm talking about
look at the scale of killing and
destruction from military organizations
and it's but my question to you is my
understanding is that when we talk about
Anarchy losing this virtual fact it's
not that it's a virtual fact of humanity
but it is a special fact of the States
because certainly their periods in
history that was it not refrigerant out
and forgive in fact that it's something
that is associated with the state system
in particular doesn't that mean that the
real problem in forming the world
governments is just that you have lots
of different actors who even if they
have a common interest in things from
our time agreeing collective action
problem and so it's a matter of finding
fund embolisms or overcoming a
collective action problem and maybe a
very simple explanation is that there's
just you know there's no hegemon or
before no one with a sufficiently strong
interest in having a world government
that can come in and provide incentives
or overcoming
well could be interpreted along the
lines of what I was saying although I
think I think we I'd like to be more
specific about what it is that they have
a hard time agreeing on so you can
certainly imagine an international world
government that's a federation and
leaves countries to do whatever they
want in terms of their policies within
their borders but that has the advantage
of getting rid of armaments and and
nationally controlled armies or say
getting rid of nationally controlled
nuclear weapons so we get out of we
worry less about terrorists or someone
acquiring nuclear weapons and having
some kind of centralized control of
course at the global level or a big
regional level and you can see that
that's something that the states would
have all kinds of reasons to agree on
and they could just leave off the table
all kinds of other stuff about cultural
policies or taxes and transfers and
things like that
so in that sense I think there you know
there is this common you know there is a
kind of clear common interest there and
the problem is though that like how
would you construct an institution that
didn't allow some party to you know take
advantage of that control of course and
use it for these other four things that
they do disagree about
last chance for anyone to weigh in can I
just ask one final sort of half question
a crustacean was very interesting and
provocative for a lot of reasons but
what about the proposition that the
puzzle you started with isn't really a
puzzle that is that those who stress the
anarchy of the international system or
let's take the political units as they
find them and don't focus on the
question of how those units came to be
formed or why that where the economic
criteria or income maximization or
primary motives that in fact anarchy has
been compromised in the Age of Empires
and that where social and political and
ideological and Nationality factors that
you discussed were the reasons that they
work in the directions you said does it
really matter for many of your arguments
that we start with that as a puzzle
could you I'm not sure I'm I'm not sure
if you're falling you're saying there
there isn't a puzzle because why well
the fact of Anarchy can be a structural
fact without investigating the question
of how the political units came to be
differentiated so you could so you know
say well I'm just gonna and then you
know yes that's right a lot of a lot of
productive and alec analysis could you
know start I'm not saying that everyone
has to start by saying why is there why
is there no world government and that
you know there are many situations where
analyzing you know they're like taking
it that not considering the option to
unify two states would you know who need
to consider that but that's just that's
a different issue from what you know
that the puzzle is pointing to is that
realists traditionally motivate what
they're you know they they're very
strong on the idea that that the
International international politics is
a veil of Tears it's it's a
like a tragic realm and it's contrasted
very sharply to you know the hierarchy
of domestic politics where these
problems do arise because there's not an
anarchy and so the puzzle is simply that
if you have if you want to teach your
students you know say like oh look at
you know anarchy is is the reason why
international politics is so different
and all they're all these bad things
that flow from it you really should have
a answer your students when they say
well why aren't you advocating world
government Tania gets the real last word
the end of it
I'm kind of blanking right now see so
for a long time I've been I felt there
was something not right about starting
with the assumption that states just
want to survive and there's a piece I
did in the annual review of political
science in 1998 it talks about this so
it's been on my mind for a long time but
it's only as it's been I'm terrified of
teaching political science 1 in the
spring which is a big large lecture
course I almost never do this and I've
never taught the course before and so
I've been you know you know I feel I got
to write the lectures in advance and
I've had this long-standing feeling that
I that there would be I wanted to try a
different way of doing an intro to IR
course than the usual models one of
which is you know isms another is kind
of problem of the week and other sort of
current events and I wanted to do
something that's more an argument from
start to finish
and it was in the course of trying to
develop an argument that those older
thoughts worries about the survival
thing and and then mixing in is you know
having worked on civil war for a while
and talk and kind of thinking about you
know so that that factored in as well
the the analogy between the world
government was kind of kind of just hit
me that you know why don't we have world
government I saw oh it's really the same
problem is what you see in civil war and
so I don't know I'm not sure you order
of those things but there you go
well thank you